but first to the virginia governor's
race that is captivating the nation
republican glenn younkin and democrat
terry mcauliffe hitting the trail ahead
of tuesday's election
and the viral campaign hoax that
everyone is talking about will probably
hurt mcauliffe the disgraced lincoln
project which has spent more than a
quarter of a million dollars on
anti-yonkin efforts is now admitting
that it orchestrated this stunt sending
this group to stand outside a yunkan bus
to pose his white supremacists with tiki
torches
mcauliffe's team quickly pounced on his
rival writing in a now deleted tweet the
unite the right rally was one of the
darkest days in the commonwealth's
history this is who glenn younkin's
supporters are
all of this comes as a brand new fox
news poll shows that yunkan is pulling
ahead of mcauliffe by an eight-point
margin a huge shift from just two weeks
before
and you can see there from the crowds
for each candidate today that momentum
is behind yunkan and it appears to be
building from angry parents who are
concerned about what their children are
being taught in school
i really like a lot of the things that
he
stands for like getting rid of critical
race theory
school choice terry mcauliffe and his
campaign implies that glenn younkin
supporters are white nationalists are
you a white nationalist sir last time i
checked on brown skin i want crt out of
our schools lower taxes and just to be
free with these crazy mandates it's
america
yeah so that guy is like uh yeah no so
you know a lot to unpack here guys but
tyrus let's start with tiki torch gate
what's your reaction to it what's the
takeaway wow
is that where we're at is that what
we're doing listen i have been talking
about this for like the last two weeks i
said it on on outnumbered i set it out
on faulkner focus gotfield america's
newsroom anyone who would listen i said
keep messing with these moms and dads
keep messing with middle class america
trying to take away the two things that
we care about a lot and that's our good
policies good policing and our education
system and telling us that we have no
say no voice and if we do speak up for
ourselves we're trying to protect our
kids we're domestic terrorists oh hell
no and then you want to make this up
congrat i called it i said there'd be a
huge upset and it's not even going to be
upset i'm calling it right now it's
gonna be a blowout and you have no one
the democratic party has no one to thank
but themselves and ridiculous racist
disgusting plots like this
well and of course lincoln project is
the group that shielded a sexual
predator and governor ralph northam is a
guy who is in blackface or a kkk road
but i digress you know jackie let's get
to the issue of education because this
is a top issue in the race as viewers
can see at home this washington post
poll
has that education is the top issue and
it's increased substantially since
september uh to october as the number
one issue here i want to play some sound
from president trump in an upcoming
interview with justin or with judge
jeanine on justice with judge jeanine
which is going to air tonight at 9 00 pm
let's take a listen to this
how do you see yunkan doing against
mcauliffe next i think he's going to do
very well look mcauliffe made a
tremendous mistake but it's really
probably not a mistake from his
standpoint he believes it right he said
the parents have nothing to do with what
their children are going to learn they
have nothing to do with it
i heard that statement i said is that
going to be bad is that going to be like
deplorables you remember when hillary
made the statement deplorables that's
not a nice word and it blew up
you know jackie what's crazy about this
is terry mcauliffe launched his race his
candidacy on the issue of education he
did it outside of an elementary school
and he went from september he was up 33
points with voters who education was
their top priority
to now younken is up by nine a 42-point
swing since september alone how does
that happen
it's a huge difference and i think it's
because people are finally waking up
realizing for example that the doj wants
to stifle them if they go to a school
board meeting and say that they don't
support critical race theory i mean
there are a lot of people out there who
want to have some input on what their
children are learning in school and they
don't want to be deemed terrorist
because they speak up they're scared to
do it now so they want someone who's
going to protect them education
certainly is a huge topic but also the
economy is really polling very high in
virginia as well when you look at
somebody like glenn younkin he is a
businessman lisa he was basically
educated at rice he got his mba at
harvard he went on to first boston then
he worked at mckinsey and then he went
on to be the ceo of the carlyle group if
you're worried about the economy if
you're worried about education and a lot
of other issues out there who better to
manage the state
than young kid and i think people are
starting to sort of look around at
what's happening especially in context
of the biden agenda right now and what
the democrats are doing with their
spending and they're saying hold on a
second here we don't want this that's
why there are checks and balances in
government
that's a great point jackie you know
sean bill maher on his show said you
know what i called this right i said
this months ago that this election could
or education could be an issue this
election let's take a listen if i could
talk to what he said
terry mccall if he was the governor he's
running again he should walk away with
it biden won the state by 10 points it
has not gone statewide for a republican
since 2009 he's neck and neck because
he's
the issue became schools i said this
months and months ago that the issue in
the coming elections is going to be
what's going on in the schools
why parents vote and they don't like
what's going on in school they feel like
they are losing control and this became
the issue in this election trust me this
is going to be a huge barometer kind of
election because terry mccall of loses
people understand yes oh that's right it
is going to be about that
yeah so sean we know that terry
mcauliffe has really tried to
nationalize the race he's trying to make
it about donald trump he's trying to say
that glenn younkin is an extremist even
though he comes across as mr rogers and
glenn younkin has he's run a very
virginia-focused race issues education
jobs etc as someone who knows a thing or
two about campaigns
what's your take on the you know talk
about the difference between those two
strategies and why it's important yeah
if i couldn't second though i think it's
important to know what bill maher just
said right i mean
voters care about a lot of things um
they might be very progressive they
might care about climate change but if
you don't have something very personal
to you going right like the nuts and
bolts like education of your child if
they're not teaching math science
english but are teaching critical race
theory all of a sudden that becomes the
number one issue because your kids are
the most important thing to you and
that's driving this turnout and i think
you know if glenn younkin wins it's
going to be obviously as we agree here
on education
uh but you know i think it's important
to look right so so the the mcculloch
campaign is trying to say listen this is
uh all donald trump republican in
virginia and obviously virginia didn't
vote for donald trump so that could be a
big hit but but junkins keeping this
right at home he's keeping on core
issues that these folks care about and
if i just make one last point when i
look at this tiki torch
lincoln project protest that you
mentioned at the start of this segment
this is a sign of failing campaigns
democrats are losing mcauliffe is losing
and therefore they try these tactics
when you're winning and everyone's
coming out and cheering you on and your
crowds are huge you don't do these kind
of things right um so i think i mean
things are looking great for um
for yunkan and uh if if you're a betting
man that's the campaign i'd be betting
on
and i also bet in terrorist shirt
i called it i'll call it america
well tyre is one for having a great
shirt but secondly because you're a
former educator look we're seeing
support for school choice skyrocket in
america do you think if yunkan wins on
tuesday republicans could replicate this
parent's first agenda in races for the
midterm elections
if they have any brains in their head
yes the first thing they would do is run
out and get deputized and start
volunteering with the local sheriff or
police office department and the second
thing will be picking up some some night
school classes and start substitute
teaching on the side yeah education
taking care and supporting our parents
and supporting our men and women who put
on that blue uniform and keep our
neighborhood safe should be on the top
thing because those two things
take care of everything else when your
kids are good you go to work fine you
don't have to stay home you don't have
to call out you know and uh school
choice yeah absolutely parents to start
thinking now we're gonna might see more
private sector education
homeschooling and getting a little your
little mother ducks get their kids
together and daddy ducks get their kids
together for pe classes and science
classes we're gonna start seeing uh one
thing with this pandemic and having a
transparent president like president
trump is people are involved now we pay
attention to the issues you can't play
the big bad wolf is coming when we're
all we're all wolves we're not worried
about that so fix my schools keep my
police employed and paid and the
democrats aren't issued in that
interested in that republicans should
not just seize on it but believe on it
and do it because if you just if you
sell wolf tickets and don't when you get
in there if he doesn't support education
he'll be out he'll be no better than the
democrats so yeah get involved
right there so some free campaign advice